et df fin des tarifs préférentiels rené
monory s'explique devant l'assemblée
yvon charpentier chez raymond barre pas
de déplafonnement des cotisations des
cadres rencontre carter dyan israël
rassurer saint-etienne manchester pas de
direct sur antenne 2 mai diffusion à
22h45
non messieurs bonsoir il est 20h et
puisque je suis là c'est donc que nous
ne sommes pas à plymouth en direct pour
le match de football manchester
saint-etienne malgré tous nos efforts
malgré tout ceux de marcel jullian le
pdg de cette chaîne se de fernand sastre
le président de la fédération française
de football nous n'avons pas pu diffuser
le match en direct
en raison de l'interdiction aberrante de
l'uefa la seule chose que nous pouvons
vous offrir
c'est la retransmission du match à 22h45
sachez tout de même et que ceux qui vont
regarder le différé se bouche les
oreilles qu'actuellement 00
je pense que vous avez bien compris que
nous avons fait le maximum tout nous a
été refusé sauf donc le différé du match
vous nous avez formidablement aider
merci pour vos livres milliers de
lettres et de coups de téléphone nous
n'en resterons pas là nous vous devons
de vous informer sur ce problème
complexe vous faire comprendre
clairement pourquoi ça n'a pas marché
nous irons jusqu'au bout pour vous
expliquer tout le fond de cette affaire
et tenter d'éviter qu'à l'avenir une
telle chose navrante puisse se
reproduire
emplacement la direction et la rédaction
d'antenne 2 vous or je crois
un beau programme il s'agit d'un débat
sur le nucléaire un débat que nous
présence georges leclercq il est à 20
mètres de moi mais dans un décor assez
futuriste
oui futuriste patrick puisque voici
superphénix la maquette de superphénix
et vous souvenez que fin juillet les
manifestations contre super phénix avait
déclenché ce besoin d'information ce
besoin de connaître nucléaire voici un
barreau de combustible g de l'uranium
ici nous avons énormément de matériel à
vous présenter ce soir avec quatre
reportages sur la vie et la sécurité
dans le nucléaire
le pèlerin comment on installe une
centrale nucléaire dans une région qui
n'en veut pas fessenheim le nouveau type
de centrales nucléaires la hague
l'endroit réputé le plus dangereux de la
chaîne du nucléaire et pourtant nous y
sommes allés et une image de
l'angleterre nucléaire tourné par claude
guignard à windscale mais patrick je
crois qu'il ya encore quelque chose un
tout petit objet que vous allez
présenter maintenant qui est presque le
clou de la soirée
parmi les cadeaux téléspectateurs
d'antenne 2
ce petit objet qui ne vous dira pas
grand chose sachez tout simplement que
c'est du plutonium
ça vaut de l'or est beaucoup plus et ça
n'est pas dangereux puisque c'est gai
mais puisque je le porte depuis voilà
trois informations de ce que l'on
appelle la vie de tous les jours le
courrier que vous écrivez les coups de
téléphone que vous passez et
l'électricité dont vous vous servez pour
le courrier un nouveau timbre qui sera
mis en vente à la mi décembre
je trouve beaucoup plus joli que
l'ancien c'est le visage d'une sabine
tiré du célèbre tableau du peintre david
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing lui même
qui a choisi ce symbole faut savoir en
effet que les sabines après les avoir
séparé avait réconcilié les romains et
les sapins alors vous voyez l'allusion à
la france coupée en deux voici donc le
nouveau visage de votre timbre un franc
et aussi à 80 centimes du côté du
téléphone vous aurez désormais des
délais pour payer on ne vous coupera
plus forcément le téléphone au bout de
quinze jours après rappel vous aurez 20
jours supplémentaires
enfin l électricité tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée le ministre rené monory en
réponse à une question du radical de
gauche alain bonnet a bien confirmé que
l'edf envisage de supprimer sa double
tarification heures creuses heures
pleines
rené monory explique le plan de l'edf ce
plan consiste d'une part à limiter le
développement du tout électrique
tout au moins tant que nous n'aurons pas
résolu notre indépendance en ce qui
concerne le nucléaire pour l'énergie
électrique et d'autre part il nous
semble que progressivement et ceci ne se
fera pas brutalement
il me semble que progressivement il est
nécessaire également de ne pas dire un
consommateur plus vous consommez moins
vous paierez je crois que nous sommes
dans une période où il faut être
absolument sérieux avec nos objectifs et
il est normal que l'on revienne très
progressivement à un prix qui correspond
à la réalité alors ne craignez pas que
cette mesure va tomber brutalement ce
que nous souhaitons c'est qu'aussi bien
gaz de france que edf puisse équilibrer
leur budget à l'avenir sans avoir besoin
de très lourdes subventions de l'état
ces subventions sont sans doute beaucoup
mieux utilisé à perdre et à des
investissements productifs d'emplois
voilà exactement quelle est la démarque
au même titre que je peux lui apporter
une pression supplémentaire en ce qui
concerne le raccordement
électrique il se trouve que ces
raccordements provoque des
investissements supplémentaires
il sera là aussi progressivement
instauré une taxe en ce qui concerne
saragosse en raccordement électrique
mais je rassure rassemble deux députés
qui m'ont posé la question
cet axe deviendra en application qu'au
mois de mai prochain de telle façon que
les usagers puissent choisir en toute
connaissance de cause
bon on est quand même un peu étonné que
pendant plusieurs années le ds nous est
en vanter les mérites de la double
tarification français ne pleurait pas
daniel estève à l'instant m'apprend que
manchester vient de marquer le premier
but du match
l'actualité à l'étranger reste dominée
par le compromis washington jerusalem
obtenu à l'arraché à l'issue de six
heures et demie de négociations non-stop
entre d'une part le président carter
puis son secret d'état et puis de
l'autre
moshe dyan qui lui a négocié de bout en
bout au nom des israéliens dont nous
vous disions hier qu'ils avaient été
plus que choqué par l'accord soviéto
américain
après 6h30 motion eye and sourit un
sourire encore crispés mais soulagé
soulagé parce que les américaines
exigent plus l'acceptation préalable par
israël de la déclaration américano
soviétique qui reconnaît la légitimité
des droits des palestiniens
il reste que carter et d'ailleurs se
sont d'accord sur un document de travail
ce document le ministre italien des
affaires étrangères
on tient des propositions nouvelles et
concrètes qui nous permettent je
l'espère qui nous permettront je
l'espère d'entamer la procédure de
convocation de la conférence de genève
moshe derian n'a pas voulu donner
l'explication sur ces propositions
nouvelles mais il a bien précisé
nous ne négocierons pas à propos d'un
état palestinien ainsi carter at-il cédé
fin de céder parce que pour lui le plus
important c'est que la conférence de
genève réussissait de son côté die and a
probablement senti qu'il ne pouvait pas
se permettre d'aller trop loin dans le
refus de faire me deuxième information
pardon de l'étranger du suis troublé par
le match elle nous concerne nous avons
obtenu l'exclusivité du reportage télé
visite du couronnement de bokassa 1er et
le 4 décembre à bangui le communiqué du
ministre centrafricain est assez
savoureux je vous le dis monsieur
elkabbach sera le seul journaliste à
détenir le document le plus recherché de
l'année nous en parlons c'est ce soir ou
demain que l'organe numéro un du pouvoir
en urss c'est à dire le plénum du comité
central du parti communiste va adopter
la nouvelle constitution soviétique
trois princes points principaux la
prédominance du parti sur les autres
institutions
l'abandon de la notion de dictature du
prolétariat avec deux ans de retard sur
les comices français et puis surtout
l'extension des libertés les libertés
vous le verrez à la manière soviétique
dans le projet de la constitution nous
avons 20 articles consacrés aux droits
de citoyen tandis que dans la
constitution ap il y en a que 9
il y a des droits nouveaux par exemple
l'eau
droit au logement le droit à la
protection de la santé le droit à
utiliser tous les richesses toutes les
richesses des cultures etc
en même temps on voit les garanties
approfondie pour les droits qui sont
déjà connus par exemple le droit à
l'éducation est garanti et c'est une
nouveauté par la distribution gratuite
des manuels scolaires le droit au
travail est garanti et c'est une
nouveauté par le choix libre du travail
et c'est donc l'élargissement des droits
des citoyens
l'approfondissement de la démocratie
socialiste
c'est ça le contenu peut être des
changements de ce chapitre mais en même
temps paradoxalement il est mentionné
plus loin que ces libertés ne doivent
pas être utilisés contre la société
telle qu'elle est alors est ce que ça ne
vous paraît pas vous professeur de droit
quelque chose de restrictive par rapport
à la somme bien venir
ça ne paraît pas contradictoire parce
que je suis professeur de droit
socialiste et toute la motion du droit
socialiste base exactement sur cette
conception nous n'avons jamais admis
donc la liberté absolue et les premiers
nice et je suis communiste ni la cette
notion donc chez nous ni cette notion de
contradictions n'ont ni la motion de la
liberté absolue par exemple et il est
interdit à moscou de faire la propagande
de la guerre tandis qu'à france je
connais c'est bien votre pige venue sur
n'importe quelle rue et criait que je
veux commencer la guerre quand on a
porté qui a vu l'ours politique on
m'arrêtera comme il est tout aussi
indécis de fun propagande contre lui
commis exactement violence politique il
est interdit de faire de la propagande
par ap contre le communisme il n'est pas
interdit d'être contre le communisme
chacun est libre dans son esprit mais il
est interdit de faire la propagande
anticommuniste et puisque nous parlons
des libertés certaines voix s'élèvent en
allemagne pour condamner une sorte de
résurgence d'un état d'esprit que nos
voisins ont déjà connu veux parler de ce
que l'on appelle la chasse aux sorcières
depuis l'enlèvement de monsieur schleyer
un mouvement d'opinion s'est dessiné
pour condamner violemment tout ce qui
peu ou prou partage les idées d'extrême
gauche par exemple écrivain günter grass
un avis intéressant recueillis par
daniel bilalian celui du cinéaste volker
schlöndorff l'auteur de caténaires
blum je crois que la tendance est
effectivement de décourager l'engagement
de pratiquement ans veut repousser
l'artiste dans la tour d'ivoire la marge
qui restent et les grandes sciences
considère comme pur artiste et qu'on dit
moi je ne sais pas je suis l'enfant
terrible je suis l'artiste je suis le
fou du roi qui a le droit de dire ce
qu'ils pensent ça je pense qu'on ne
serait pas tout de suite inquiété mais
si tout en étant artiste izon cinéaste
mois et qu'en même temps on veut
s'engager par exemple dans la politique
culturelle en ce qui concerne le soutien
au cinéma qu'on veuille s'engager
d'une façon générale pour les avocats
pour les procès pour des prisonniers
également de droit commun à ce moment là
vous n'avez plus la possibilité d'agir
en vous demande de ne pas penser
politiquement mais de penser en
politicien par exemple moi on dit ah oui
bouche le nord vous pouvez dire ça mais
en tant que peut-être être étant proche
du parti social démocrate
il faut pas vous que vous pensiez
politiquement mais moi je pense
politiquement ce qu'ils veulent dire ce
que je pense
en politicien pour ne pas dire en
politique car ils demandent finalement
une autocensure qu'il est indigne de
pratiquer on ne peut pas demander à
l'artiste de se distancier par exemple
d'une action criminelle parce que jamais
il ne l'aurait approuvé mais alors
pourquoi cette volonté de le faire en
sorte que l'ue n'a ni personne ne puisse
sortir de cette unanimité
je me demande pourquoi on veut se
rassurer comme ça je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de réel danger
c'est un des états les plus prospères et
les plus sûres et les moins menacés qui
soit pourquoi réagir avec une telle
démesure
je crois que c'est très dangereux
la politique française en quelques
flashs la pires âneries la piraterie
pardon aérienne en conseil des ministres
de tels procédés sont indignes des
nations civilisées a dit le chef de
l'état qui a renouvelé au gouvernement
ses consignes permanente de sang-froid
et de fermeté je cite pas de
chaptalisation des vins du languedoc et
du roussillon a deal secret d'état
jacques blanc donc pas de dérogation
pour les vignerons du midi ne
pratiqueront à dix ministres aucune
démagogie électorale ministre qui va
prendre connaissance d'un plan de cinq
ans de sauvegarde de la viticulture
française présentée aujourd'hui au
conseil économique et social par louis
louga
l'ancien président du cni accord
salarial aux charbonnages de france
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
dans la fonction publique et fo la cftc
et la cgc signe la cgt et la cfdt ont
refusé enfin une entrevue cet après midi
entre raymond barre et yvon charpentier
le président de la cgc entrevue
apparemment enrichissante pour yvan
charpentier satisfait des assurances du
premier ministre la première c'est que
le gouvernement semble reconnaître la
nécessité de la pérennité du régime
complémentaire de retraite est donc le
premier ministre a décidé qu'il n'y
aurait pas de déplafonnement 1978 comme
conséquence également nous voyons nous
avons vu apparaître le décret qui va
fixer le plafond de la sécurité sociale
pour les années futures et qu'il fera
que les ressources de nos régimes ne
seront pas amputé par une progression
anarchique de ce plafond également le
gouvernement entend mettre à l'étude le
projet fiscal que nous lui avons soumis
qui doit permettre de combattre le
chômage derrière permettre le
développement des entreprises tout en
essayant d'associer cette étude à ce qui
pourrait être une actionnariat de
l'encadrement et la représentation de
l'encadrement dans les conseils
d'administration ou dans les conseils de
surveillance des entreprises et nous
disons que nous sommes satisfaits sur
les réponses qui nous ont été données
est ce que ces assurances vont faire
pencher les caps du côté de la majorité
à écouter
nous n'avons pas parlé politique avec le
premier ministre c'est une toute autre
affaire
et ceux qui voudraient voir de résultats
que nous avons obtenus une attitude
politique se tromperait très
certainement les députés ont amendé le
texte sur l'informatique et les libertés
c'est la composition de la commission
qui ne plaisait pas aux parlementaires
dans la nouvelle version 3 membres
seulement seront choisis par le
gouvernement les neuf autres seront des
magistrats choisis par leurs corps
une nouvelle réunion des formations de
la majorité ce matin pour poursuivre
l'étude des circonscriptions électorales
et puis à nouveau partie vous savez
l'union des français de bon sens son
fondateur gérard furnon et ce directeur
d'une usine dans le gard qui ne voulait
pas entendre parler de la cgt chez lui
cet après midi il présentait son état
major avec tout d'abord un adjoint qui
vous dira quelque chose aussi
joël dupuch le fameux sergent dupuis sa
ligne de conduite ni à droite ni à
gauche un mouvement anti parti qui se
veut rassembler jaune du côté de
l'opposition réunion depuis ce matin du
comité central du parti communiste
réunion très importante qui se terminera
demain
ce n'est qu'à ce moment là que l'on
saura par la bouche de jean jour marché
ce qui s'y est dit chez les socialistes
gaston defferre sur france inter ce
matin n'a pas jugé réaliste la
proposition du crs de convocation rapide
d'un congrès du parti
en tout cas qu'on voudrait ou pas les
socialistes font le forcing en ce moment
pour expliquer leur position vous allez
le voir dans ce reportage de bernard
prat vino qui est en quelque sorte le
pendant de l'enquète que patricia charme
ne l'avait fait l'autre jour dans une
fédération communiste
périphériques apple france et jusqu'au
bord du périphérique
la crise de la gauche vient d'une série
de malentendus
tout va s'arranger les militants
socialistes du pré saint gervais qui
m'explique ceux là sont optimistes
moyenne d'âge un peu plus de 30 ans
depuis quelques jours ils collent leurs
affiches avec beaucoup d'énergie
il faut absolument expliqué que le parti
socialiste reste fidèle à l'union de la
gauche
la querelle des états majors politiques
à semble-t-il renforcer la détermination
des militants
le maire socialiste du pré-saint-gervais
marcel debarge vient d'être élu sénateur
il est partout à la fois colored
affiches et animateur des réunions de la
section en fait cette réunion s'ajoutent
à celles qui ont lieu habituellement
aujourd'hui il est nécessaire de faire
le point et de bien se comprendre les
gens ne pouvaient pas comprendre le
faisons quand ça ne va pas comprendre
qu'on a six mois avant il faut tomber
d'accord sans voix minimum et vous il
faut que les partis communistes seront
brèves que pour nous il s'agit je crois
de conserver l'unité
pour nous il s'agit de faire l'union de
la gauche ne s'agit pas de perdre union
de la gauche
abraham communiste
en commun une affiche qui dit et
socialistes tiennent promesse
il ne promet que ceux qui peuvent tenir
c'est je crois véritablement leitmotiv
actuelle du parti socialiste
pas de démagogie et encore une fois la
vérité politique n'appartient pas un
seul parti en ce qui concerne la gauche
il n'a plus cette semaine que le jour du
marché
qu'à cela ne tienne les militants
socialistes sont là prêts à répondre aux
questions prêt au dialogue
la seine-saint-denis est un département
à majorité électorale communiste sur
trois personnes rencontrées chaque
militant socialiste a des chances de
distribuer son tract à un communiste la
discussion sous les parapluies se fait
réellement à la base parce que de toute
façon y aura un programme commun de la
gauche avec les fonctions du parti
socialiste et les parties communes
mais on papa de cette étape c'est une
interruption d'une intéressante analyse
le crédit
en plus je viens me permets de côté
d'avoir un jour là
d'avoir les dents leur ont déjà une
implantation les entreprises
pourquoi tout nationaliser pourquoi pas
plus nationaliser même pas 1% tout
nationaliser la crise est quand même là
même 20% malgré la crise
ou peut-être à cause d'elle les
militants socialistes du
pré-saint-gervais n'ont rien perdu de
leur enthousiasme
voilà encore un petit peu de football
que ceux qui veulent nous regarder tout
à l'heure n'écoute pas le résultat à la
mi-temps 1-0 pour manchester
enfin aujourd'hui après de multiples
reports le procès du cs pailleron je
devrais dire le premier des deux procès
quatre ans et demi après ce tragique
incendie
il y aura procès des responsables de la
construction et il ya eu aujourd'hui
donc le procès des deux jeunes
incendiaires
patrick et marques qui ont 19 et 20 ans
à l'époque au lefebvre il en avait 14 et
15 pas vu aujourd'hui ce sont des
adultes dont la maturité si on peut dire
a été profondément troublé par le
souvenir les conséquences de l incendie
qui sont allumés le 6 février 73 20
victimes dont 16 ans est victime ses
enfants à leur âge alors l'un d'eux a
retrouvé une vie de famille en province
où personne ne le connaît plus et
l'autre a été pris longtemps en charge
par l'éducation surveillée il tente
d'oublier
et d'après ce que je crois savoir leur
départ dans la vie n'est pas très facile
d'autant que leur avenir dans un premier
temps est hypothéquée par la
condamnation qui va être prononcée alors
est ce que aujourd'hui ce procès a
encore une signification
j'avoue je n'en sais rien parce que le
seul point de référence dans cette
affaire c'est l'extraordinaire dignité
des parents des victimes qui ont
toujours tenu à séparer les les
responsabilités d'abord un geste
d'enfants stupide révélateur d'une sorte
de mal à l'aise dans la vie il ne savait
pas qu exceptionnellement ce soir là le
crs était occupée du moins en partie
et puis on la responsabilité des
constructeurs qui va être que 0,8 à
l'heure au cours d'un très long procès
technique en novembre alors juger un
adulte quatre ans après une faute
d'enfants
quatre années durant lesquelles il a
vécu dans ce souvenir terrible pendant
lesquels il a toujours vécu mille fois
je ne sais pas très bien où est la
justice et ce n'est surtout sur quoi
elle va déboucher en la matière manière
pages de ce journal maintenant le métro
dans quelques semaines un nouveau
tronçon est une nouvelle station du rer
parisien aux halles dans quelques
semaines
la mise en service du métro lyon et puis
c'était depuis quelques jours les
premiers travaux de construction d'un
métro à lille une initiative qui devrait
réjouir tout le monde dans la métropole
du nord mais qui en fait pose au moins
autant de problèmes qu'elle n'en résout
vous allez le voir les transports en
commun de l'agglomération lille roubaix
tourcoing qui regroupe un million
d'habitants répartis sur 87 communes
s'avérait défectueuse insuffisant la
communauté urbaine de lille a donc en
mars 74 définitivement votée et opter
pour le métro ce métro s'appellera le
val véhicule automatique léger
en clair cela veut dire que le métro
lillois marchera de façon entièrement
automatique sans conducteur ni receveur
ces voitures seront d'un petit gabarit
monté sur pneus depuis l'annnonce de
cette décision bon nombre d'associations
se sont créés s'élevant contre la
création du val elle conteste en premier
son tracé en effet distel la première
ligne ira d'est en ouest et reliera la
cité scientifique de villeneuve d'ascq à
la cité hospitalière de lille
toujours d'après ces associations les
seuls d'usagé de cette ligne seront des
étudiants qui ne travaille qu environ
huit mois par an à des horaires
irréguliers et les usagers qui ont le
privilège de travailler et d'habiter sur
ce même parcours
la ligne sera donc peu fréquentées elle
aurait été plus utile sur l' axe sud
nord et aurait participé au
développement économique de roubaix et
tourcoing
la deuxième inquiétude des détracteurs
et la crainte de l'urbanisation sauvage
qui risque de s'installer sur certains
tronçons entraînant ainsi la disparition
des espaces verts et la construction de
viaducs
troisièmement ces groupements trouve
trop élevé le prix de cette réalisation
du fait de son coût extrêmement élevé il
va vraisemblablement stopper la remise
en question et l'amélioration du système
de transport en commun de la métropole
par conséquent il ne va faire que
bloquer l'état actuel qui est
extrêmement peu efficace et peu
satisfaisant pour l'ensemble des
habitants de la ville car c'est un
système extrêmement centralisé avec des
lignes rayonnante à partir de la guerre
ce qui fait que la plupart des habitants
habitant et travaillant en banlieue ne
peuvent pas prendre les transports en
commun et ne pourront pas plus utilisé
transports en commun lorsque le métro
existera je dis qu'on va jeter dans un
paris absolument époustouflant on va
gérer 200 à 250 milliards d'argent
public
c'est dramatique j'ai connu la villette
j'ai connu le concorde chez colette plan
calcul on va faire sur le plan régional
la même expérience
moi je vois la solution à l'intérieur de
la ville de lille beaucoup plus dans la
densification d'un réseau d'autobus
souple et adaptable utilisant un certain
nombre de méthodes modernes comme on l'a
fait déjà ailleurs et comme on a
commencé d'ailleurs à le faire à lille
c'est à dire les couloirs d'autobus les
ondes verbe l'informatique pour qu'un
métro soit efficace il faut que chaque
usager puissent se rendre de son
domicile à son lieu de travail que la
ville soit entièrement quadrillé de la
vie des détracteurs du vally loi on
aurait pu à lille procéder comme à
bruxelles
les belges ont enterré leurs tramways et
se sont pliés aux infrastructures des
transports en commun déjà existantes en
les perfectionnant pour en l'an 2000
posséder enfin un métro digne des
grandes capitales et utile à tous à
bruxelles on a commencé par le pré métro
et métro c'est construire des ouvrages
d'infrastructure au gabarit métro
devenir a pas de voile et démolir plus
tard et à les utiliser progressivement
tronçon par tronçon kilomètre par
kilomètre dirais-je parlait tramway en
construisant à l'extrémité d'une
certaine longueur
ouvrage des rampes d'accès c'est ça le
pré métro et le pré métro à la faculté
de pouvoir être étendue on allonge le
tunnel d'un kilomètre ou deux on déplace
la rampe d'accès ou bien il a aussi la
faculté de pouvoir se construire par
tronçons séparés aux endroits
névralgiques de la ville et luther your
man il peut être converti en métro du
côté de la communauté urbaine et de la
mairie de lille on estime avoir trop
parlé de la sphère du métro et on
observe le mutisme le plus absolu
quant à l'exécution du projet la réponse
appartiendra au tribunal administratif
qui est saisie de la faire par les
opposants au projet
vous gagnez voilà un sujet que vous a
fait réagir
oui c'est un sujet qui me tient à coeur
parce que le métro s'est toujours posé
des questions là tu ferais remarquer
d'abord que vous avez observé aucun
partisan du métro c'est à dire la
communauté urbaine de lille n'a répondu
c'est dommage il n'y a pas de raison ce
n'est pas parce que le coup est parti il
faut pas continuer à dialoguer la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que après lyon après marseille
tous les experts ont dit il faut plus
faire de métro en dessous de 2 millions
d'habitants
alors on en fait un lille c'est pas le
procédé qui est en cause qui est très
bon c'est le principe du métro et je
crois que c'est une erreur une erreur
pourquoi parce que le métro coûte quatre
fois plus cher que le tramway à
l'investissement est deux fois plus cher
au fonctionnement or le tramway c'est
très bien saviez vous par exemple que la
ville de france qui transporte le plus
de personnes partent par an en transport
en commun c'est la ville de
saint-etienne elle le fait en tramway et
puis je tirais enfin qui a sans employer
les grands mots peut-être un problème
philosophique qui se pose le métro c'est
un peu le tunnel et la vie pour beaucoup
c'est peut-être aussi bien qu elle l'est
quand on dit métro boulot dodo ce n'est
peut-être pas un hasard
y a pas que le dodo il ya aussi les
bandes dessinées encore un baptême de
magazines bonne chance à notre confrère
bd une l'hebdomadaire de la bande
dessinée la course autour du monde à la
voile de bateau viennent d'arriver au
cap terme de la première étape
fly suivi de kingsley jones les deux
bateaux séparé par deux heures seulement
vont aller contre 2 heures sur plus d'un
mois et demi de course je n'enverrais
pas sur le football vous rappelle
simplement le résultat à la mi-temps 1-0
pour manchester et je vous donne
rendez-vous à 22h45 pour l'intégralité
du match en différé tout en regrettant
cette affaire assez navrante
le loto pour terminer le 4 sept
le 12 le 28 le 36 le 49 et en numéro
complémentaire vous le voyez le 30 sept
le temps il sera hélas médiocre demain
sur l'ensemble du pays avec de fortes
averses sur le sud essentiellement les
vents seront assez forts un peu partout
et les températures baisseront
je n'avais pas que des choses agréables
vous dire ce soir
trois rendez vous dans quelques minutes
20h30
le débat sur le nucléaire 22h45 le match
00h15 le dernier journal de patrick
lecocq bonsoir à tous à demain